(electronic music)
- I sleep on a futon,
I've been using the same
Brita for three years.
My roommate is a bassist.
Don't tell me I'm not
fucking putting cooking
fuck fucks suck fuck.
- Alright.
God damn mother fucker.
Don't look at him when
he gets like this!
- [Cameraman] (grunting loudly)
(giggling)
- Sorry!
(beep)
Silly me, I thought we.
Wow, wow.
- That's fine, that's fine.
(beep)
- [Girl] Ewwww.
- I just, I almost vomited.
Sorry.
(laughing)
- [Amy] And one day,
I'm stuffing cous cous
into a calzone and I realized
a woman's life is worth.
- I'm so sorry.
- [Amy] JJ, I'm telling
you my real shit right now.
- I'm so sorry, and
I care about it.
Can we just take a
break from our life?
I wrote to you, I wrote to you.
Aw man (beep).
- [Amy] What'd you write?
(beep)
- I wrote to you, I
wrote to you today.
(laughing)
I'm so sorry.
(beep)
- Unless you change
the dialogue.
If anyone can do it, it's you.
I'm sorry.
- Sorry.
So sorry.
(laughing)
So smooth.
(beep)
And if you wanted an apple,
well you'd have to eat pie.
That's why I'm not gonna
give you what you ordered.
(beep)
- That apple stayed on
his shirt the whole time.
That was torture.
(beep)
- [Girl] JJ?
Someone emptied their butt
in the women's bathroom.
(cast and crew laughing)
(Inside Amy Schumer Theme Song)